de matignon ou encore l'exemple du musée
de l'air au bourget avec l'arrivée du
dernier le concorde qui est entré dans
l'histoire diego garcia sylvain doba
cette fois l'oiseau blanc est en cage
mais ici au musée du bourget la magie
perdure malgré la nostalgie
le concorde c'est quoi pour vous
le supersonique était déjà un monument
en vol il est maintenant cloués au sol
et comme les autres monuments on lui
rend visite en cette journée du
patrimoine le contrat représente
l'aboutissement de la technologie
aéronautique du 20e siècle et à ce titre
là c'est un élément extraordinaire du
patrimoine du musée de l'air en 1969 il
effectue son premier vol on dit de lui
qu'il est bruyant arrogant avec ses
formes étranges
3h55 pour relier new york contre 7
heures 45 pour un avion classique une
prouesse technologique un gouffre
financier
trente quatre ans plus tard en juin
dernier il finit sa carrière sur le
tarmac de l'aéroport charles de gaulle
quand il passait quand le vent était
favorable qui passe au dessus de chez
moi tous les jours je sortais loi c'est
toujours
c'est toujours différent toujours la
même joie et rugit fait au loin vers
caracas rio de janeiro new york entre
autres près d'un million et demi de
passagers ont emprunté le concorde sous
les couleurs d'air france il reste 5
exemplaires du supersonique trois se
trouvent en france les autres sont
exposées en allemagne et aux etats unis
aujourd'hui même s'il a tiré sa
révérence ici laventure du concorde
continue